the copilot deliberately caused the  Airbus to descend until it crashed into  a mountain that is the startling message  from French investigators a public  prosecutor said no other conclusion was  possible from the analysis of voice  recorder data as the plane went down the  copilot was alone in the cockpit lat  about that sort of proposing reversal  for us the most plausible and most  reasonable interpretation bowing up  still is that the copilot deliberately  locked the cabin door and refused to  open it gavina locked out the pilot  tried to return to the cockpit in vain  this Airbus video shows how the locking  mechanism works the door opens when a  code is entered a camera shows the  pilots in the cockpit who's trying to  come in they have a switch that prevents  the door from opening it's a precaution  that's been in place since the terrorist  attacks of September 11 2001 now it has  cost 149 people their lives